super stimmung beim vokuhila festival im
australischen karikari vokuhila steht
für vorne kurz hinten lang auch als
fußballer frisur bekannt in australien
heißt der haarschnitt mallett beim
ballett festival raten 150 teilnehmer in
fünf kategorien an
die entscheidende frage wer hat die
haare am schönsten
ich habe meine frisur seit 1972 waren
die meisten anderen noch gar nicht
geboren
auch für frauen und kinder gibt es beim
festival eigene wettkampfklassen dabei
sein ist alles und spaß ist eigentlich
garantiert veranstalterin laura johnson
hier in kari sind wir fest davon
überzeugt dass wir den mal erfunden
haben
wir haben ihnen am längsten und wir
wollen unseren bürgern die chance geben
zu zeigen was sie haben und auch dass
sie auf dem neuesten stand sind und
wirklich rock dass die vokuhila frisur
wirklich aus australien kommt es nicht
bewiesen und wird sicherlich vielerorts
gestritten
auch ob die mannes über karikari hinaus
wieder in mode kommen darf bezweifelt
werden
[Applaus]